all right so the predator is out now so
there's my predator spoiler talk or
spoiler review spoiler video that's a
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
predator you probably shouldn't watch
this if you don't give a [ __ ] we'll
stick around and watch it YouTube is
gonna get buried in terms of views and
hits anyway means those of you who watch
it here's the real fans you stop this
[ __ ] out and as always this isn't gonna
be a play-by-play just gonna jump around
and talk about some spoilers things we
couldn't talk about before so the
predator starts out you see a predator
ship on the run from another predator
ship it creates a wormhole he comes
early she's actually kind of cool you
find out this predators on the run from
his government pretty much to what is
it's now an espionage predator spy movie
which is a question what's the better
spy comedy spy or the predator ship
crash-lands he starts killing main dudes
unit and main dude says hey I saw an
alien males all the [ __ ] to his Pio box
which ends up at his house and his kid
gets it he'll is a guy accidentally
which is pretty gratifying when the kid
it's Halloween so the kids were in the
predator helmet
this guy's a dick and he throws
something at the kids helmet and then
the rocket just goes come bad blows the
dude I was like that's amazing cuz we
all got picked on in school right if we
had that tech we probably would have
used it which is probably why we should
never have it which if we're gonna get
real for a second the kids now gonna
have to deal with the fact that he's
gonna feel responsible for killing that
guy probably not gonna feel good about
it he obviously doesn't view death as a
good thing even talks with his dad about
deaths when the rocket goes back blows
the dude up kids probably gonna need
therapy this is a comedy so we're not
supposed to think about that stuff so
let's just go on I guess and when you
males the predator attack to his kid he
swallows the blue predator tech ball
that turns people invisible I guess it's
a ball that does it but he just gobbles
it down which it establishes the
students not the brains of the operation
he's not the smart one of the family his
kid is that's still pretty irresponsible
but why'd you swallow it but is just
mail it back with the rest of the tech
your mail into your p.o box why'd you
swallow that that's a piece of alien
tech off of an alien from an alien world
how radioactive is that thing your body
could had a very adverse reaction to it
turned out fine for him in the end but
it could have just as easily been like
down the hatch small with an alien tech
ball a little tingly but you know other
than that all in all I I feel pretty
good
[Music]
that you still feel like that's a smart
thing to do so they think the threat is
the normal predator that we see because
the Predators slaughtered a whole room
of people including Gary Busey's kid
Jake Busey
Jake B C's character in this movie plays
the son of Gary Busey's character and
predator - after slaughter housing all
these people you find out that's what
predators do is they take the best
warriors on a planet and they kind of
annex their DNA into a predator and now
they've kind of adopted traits I guess
which is fascinating is that what
they've been doing this whole time is
that what they were doing in predators
also do they do that to the aliens like
that they fought and killed aliens I
don't think this movie goes on AVP lore
I believe it's just predator and
predator - because they referenced
predator and predator - at the end of
predator - there's that alien skull in
the scull cage did they get the traits
from aliens in which case do they have
acid blood they don't someone touches
the Predators blood in here's I would
imagine that would be the most
advantageous trait of an alien this is
where I find out that someone somewhere
said that that's actually not an alien
skull so now this franchise is doing
that thing where the later movies are
changing lore and motivation which means
looking back it changes the context of
the previous movie last yet I kind of
ran into that with me and so that's what
the predator is now gonna run into with
me the big predator pummels little
predator rips his head off with his
spine to harvest his DNA I guess oh now
they got a deal with big predator in
which guns just don't hurt the guy he
does have two big dogs though I wasn't
really weird saying though when one dude
comes and just plugs the dog predator
right there dog predator was really
vicious and I was super nice dog like
did he take out a microchip and his
brain like how what did that do
lobotomizing my guess but it doesn't
seem lobotomize he just seems like a
nice dog he's playing in fact she's
bringing people corn aids the comedies
and we're not supposed to think about
that stuff so let's just go on I guess
so then you find out the smaller
predator not that big one that's hunting
them but the little one who got killed
by the big predator he came here to give
us a gift to help us because global
warming the Earth's are dying maybe the
Predators just want to move in which
case the best way to fight off the
Predators is to make this world kind of
unlivable for them which means fix our
[ __ ] but instead go ahead and settle for
weapons and it didn't make too much
sense to me like this predator comes
down it's killing people the entire time
but he's a good guy he cares he wants to
help humanity why wouldn't he just
disarm people why wouldn't he shoot like
guns out of their hands why would he
just kill people I know where there's
predators like I'm here to help you
because I love you Merry Christmas
here's a supersuit this is the comedies
that we're not supposed to think about
that stuff so let's just go on I guess
so going to the end a little kid who has
Asperger's he's the one that the
predator the super predator wants to
take his DNA he's like that's the
warrior like Olivia Munn said in the
movie we see things like that is
disorders maybe they're not disorders
maybe they're the next stage of human
evolution evolution by and large is a
series of mistakes that's led us here
we can't grip branches with our feet
what a mistake yet here we are I
actually really like that that's a deep
philosophical discussion this movie is
begging to have so then they crash the
ship blow the limbs off a big predator
and man guys like what the hell are you
or something like that he delivers the
line he goes shut the [ __ ] up what I
literally thought that's just lazy
writing I know I just makes him seem
like kind of a knucklehead
I guess he's supposed to be kind of a
knucklehead but they just fade to black
and it's over and just came across as
anticlimactic but then we get the next
scene which is the end scene which I'm
pretty sure are the reshoots we heard
about they opened the Predators gift and
it's a little thing that latches onto a
dudes arm and creates a super predator
suit so we can fight predators I guess
it reminded me of a toy I had when I was
young it was an alien toy like from
aliens it was a person you snap all
these bits on them and then they're
actually like a big robotic version of
aliens so they can fight aliens it was
just like that only for predator but I
was like what the [ __ ] did I chose a lot
I feel like a toy company was like we
need a toy but it needs to be new like
everyone has predator toys now everyone
has marine toys we need something else
make a predator toy like that alien toy
from the 90s we're good your hot toys is
chiseling away like [ __ ] you then the
movie ends and that's the predator and
to elaborate on a point I brought up in
my review of the predator I threw out
there that movies are more funny now and
the predator is a funny movie because
MCU movies are funny which I guess just
offended the [ __ ] out of a few people
because Shane black always makes funny
movies maybe just thought I was full of
[ __ ] because Shane black makes funny
movies I know Shane Black makes funny
movies it actually speaks to the point
that they hired a funny director to
direct a predator movie but the question
is why I don't think it's too
far-fetched to hypothesize a causality
other movies franchises and Studios have
more humor interjected in their
entertainment because possibly it works
for the MCU I think is a fair question a
fairy proposal and I'm more leaning
towards that's probably why it's
happening so it's a Kinect
I see but that's just me looking in from
the outside I don't know I'm not there
in the board meetings the pitch meetings
the writers meetings I just want to live
in a world where every movies a funny
ass movie now I don't need jokes in
everything I love chocolate syrup I'm
not gonna put chocolate syrup on
everything because food metaphors are my
thing but we all understand food that's
just an easy connection to make for me
some humor works in most movies like
I've said before some humor some
deflection that just keeps things human
because life has humor in it more humor
works for some movies and some
franchises take the MCU for example it
works there it's fine it's fun making
every character a comedian I just don't
think works for a predator movie in the
end this movie I don't hate it might be
a little more enjoyable with a drink the
things that irritated me in the movie
some could call it nitpicks I call them
observations else we quantify myself as
less douchey than I probably am in real
life all right so again I'll ask you the
predator have you seen it what did you
think about it what do you think about
movies adopting humor into their
franchises into the movies let me know
if you see what I see or maybe you see
things a little differently suppose
we'll run to a bit of a chicken in the
egg scenario the more we think about it
go down the rabbit hole but yeah well
those are fun to contemplate tale but
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]